thank you Yasser we are indeed with
dingly ran our new world chess champion
first of all uh ding welcome to the show
but also it's our first opportunity to
congratulate you officially so
congratulations what an incredible match
tell us a bit about your journey from
Astana here to Bucharest was it
difficult uh are you tired how do you
feel uh emotionally as well as
physically right now after this very
difficult Workshop instrument yeah after
a watch after match I'm exhausted
and but at least I have several days to
rest in Asana and then I
I come there yeah
the flight was at midnight it's quite
late
but I feel
pretty pretty good after arriving there
I
yeah and definitely such an important
Victory gives you a boost of uh
confidence how do you feel right now as
the world Channel
yeah but the tournament continues and
there are many tournaments ahead
so I will try to yeah
take it one step at a time just adjust
to this new status of yours tell us
about the first game
um here at the Grand chess tour against
mvl
oh he prays this line did he surprise
you with
taking on C4 yeah I expected him to play
the greenfeld
here
yeah probably B3 which I played many
times uh
a million times online and offline
yeah the last time I played this
variation was I remember was over the
board game against Hikaru in 2019 where
I played Knight D2
continuous B5 which would be to Bishop
B7
this time I played Bishop E2 what are
some of the ideas of this move Bishop
uh
uh in that game he played B5 now I
didn't go and I did two I play A4
instead
you also maybe have some ideas of Bishop
F3 yeah but not now if Bishop F3 uk7
okay seven and that's good for for black
so A4 you immediately attack this Pawn
on B5 that's the change of the structure
yeah
yeah take take Knight D2 and here I was
expecting 96
I'm
Bishop takes uh so Knight C6 would have
been a blunder uh in fact for for MPL
but he did see it I I guess he played
the move Knight d7. yes it's quite good
to
put the Rook on A5 yeah H6 maybe he's
still in preparation since he plays this
move within 10 minutes yeah it's almost
just surprised me but maybe the idea is
just to wait to play a waiting move or
are you surprised that he was ready for
this particular line no I was surprised
for just this move H6 to do nothing on
the queen side to make waiting move on
the king sides
so what's White's plan what was your
plan and here I had many many moves Rook
D1 Rook C1
is uh two most
hmm
uh seemed to me most
a nature move
yeah so you play The Rook C1 C1 yes
to play nicely for
Queen C7
and this in fact seems to be the best
way for him to continue as well so maybe
it's the best also the best way for me
to
to try to get a playable position not
like the game yeah
and you play in The Rook to C1 after
some thought through the C8 yeah
actually here when playing before I
decided to make the Quick Draw just to
make a quick draw after before
simplifying the position yeah
um how do you feel about your chances in
this tournament
um I know you must have spent a lot of
energy in the previous month but now you
have to get back in the saddle yeah step
by step at least and today I
I feel much better than the previous
tournament normally I
I pray very bad with the first White
games I lost many wise games in the
previous tournament so today at least I
got the job
thing congratulations once again for uh
your incredible Victory and we're
looking forward to see what you have in
store for us in this tournament okay
thank you thank you guys back to you
thank you Christian as we have a single
result thus far doing drawing with MBL